If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the rest is history.com and click gifts. This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionised the future with the might of industrial power. But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of hive. Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible for you
to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow. Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke, no waste. Hive's EV charger lets your car charge quietly overnight, recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together, heating, charging and solar, managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution. In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more, subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected technology. Paid for a surplus requires SEG tariff.
Hello everyone and I hope you had a wonderful Christmas. Now we have two festive treats coming up for you today and on Thursday. And these are two halves of a show that we recorded at the Royal Albert Hall on the 4th of May this year with a full orchestra and professional opera singers. And it has to be said, me. So like last year's episodes on Mozart and Beethoven, these episodes will be accompanied with music. The first episode, today's episode, is on Tchaikovsky,
and Thursday's episode will be on Wagner. Enjoy. I'm I'm going to be able to be the I'm going to I'm I'm going I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm So, I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. And so,
you know, I'm . I'm going to be the I'm going to be I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to
I'm a I'm the I'm a new, the way. The way, I'm going to be. And so on the
I'm not the way I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
and I'm I'm and I'm I'm You know, the I'm going to be able to be.
Thank you. So welcome or welcome back to the rest history live with the orchestra. We have the amazing Philimonial Orchestra here with us. And today we're playing probably my two favorite composers, Tchaikovsky and Wagner. So here to tell you more about them are Tom Holland and Dominic Sandbrook. Hello Kensington Gore and welcome to the rest is history. Dominic, it's fantastic to be back at the Royal Albert Hall, isn't it? And thank you so much, everyone, for coming.
And wow, do we have a show this evening. We do indeed. So we will be talking about not just two of Oliver's favourite composers, but two of the greatest composers who have ever lived. Their lives, a brilliant window into the surging passions of the 19th century. So we'll be in Russia under the Tsars. We'll be in Germany, in the age of business. Mark, a world of romantic idealism, of sexual secrets, of Tom, some very pungent politics.
Very pungent. We do like pungent politics on the rest is history. This show really does have it all. It really does. And you've already had a flavour of the music we're going to be hearing this evening. So that, of course, was the opening of Chikovsky's Ballet Swan Lake, first performed in 1877, and as Ollie said, played by the Philharmonia Orchestra and conducted by the equally brilliant Oliver Zethmann.
And we should start by paying tribute to Oliver because these shows were his idea. He literally put the band together. And as you will find out, and as you've already discovered, with that wonderful performance of Swan Lake, he's not half bad at conducting either. Not bad at all.
But let's get right into our first story, and this is the life of perhaps the most romantic and certainly the most flamboyantly Russian of all the great composers. Right, exactly. So, this whole show that we have for you this evening is very much a 19th century affair, and we're going to kick off in the year 1840,
because that is the year that a young Piotr Ilyich-Cykovsky was born in a little iron-making town called Votsynsk, which is about 600 miles east of Moscow in the foothills of the Urals. So we are deep in the heart of Russia. We're in a classic Russian landscape. They're kind of churches with their golden domes, the vast fields, the deep birch and beach forests. It's the kind of landscape that is familiar if you've read Tolstoy or Dostoevsky or any of the great Russian novelist. Exactly, exactly.
So to give you a bit of context, Russia at the time is an autocracy ruled by the Romanov Tsars. And it's got this vast population of serfs and peasants. Now, it's often described as a backward country. But that's not necessarily true in every respect. Russia has been expanding at a colossal rate by 1840 when Charkovsky's born. It's a vast continental empire all the way from Finland and Poland to the Caucasus and the Pacific. And Tchaikovsky's family is doing well out of the Russian Empire, isn't it? So his father manages the local ironworks, they've got servants.
And actually, shocking detail, Dominic, his – Chikovsky's mother's family are actually French. They are Huguenots who fled to Russia as refugees. So we're not holding that against them. No, we don't hold that against him. So he even actually had a French governess, and we know a few details about Tchaikovsky's early life from the French governor. She said he was a bright boy,
but incredibly sensitive. She said he was as brittle as porcelain, a child of glass. And Tom, very much like our goalhanger stablemates. We actually have Rory Stewart with us in the audience, and nobody would ever say Rory was as brittle as porcelain. Of course not. Of course not.
So the Tchaikovsky's, they're not a tremendously musical family, actually, as it happens. I mean, they do have a piano, but basically everyone who's middle class in the 19th century has a piano, and none of them are very good at playing it. No, they're not terribly good at it, but then one day, Piotr's father, Ilya, comes home from St. Petersburg. He's been in a business trip, and he has this kind of barrel organ called an orchestrion. And the point of this machine is that would basically mimic the sound of an entire orchestra.
So we wouldn't actually need the Philharmonia if we could only invest it in one of those. Oliver's life would be so much easier. So this is how the young Chikovsky falls in love with music. Basically, you feed a sheet into this thing, and you turn it. It could be Mozart's greatest hits, and away you go. And actually, it's Mozart that Chikovsky really falls in love with. Mozart becomes his great hero. So in the next few years, the family move around quite a bit.
They see the cities, St. Petersburg and Moscow. They go to different places in the Urales. And I often wonder whether this is, the fact that they move around, whether this gives Chikovsky one of his defining traits, which is an extraordinary affinity with the people and landscape of Russia, this intense sense of patriotism. Much later on in life, he wrote, I have never come across anyone more in love with Mother Russia than me.
I love Russian people, the Russian language, the Russian way of thinking, I love the sacred legends of the dim and distant past, I love it all. But I mean, almost the paradox of this is that even as it's very Russian, It's also very European, isn't it? Because European culture is still very marked by romanticism, by the cult of landscape, the cult of sensibility, and I guess above all the cult of nationalism. So all sorts of writers and composers across Europe,
not just in Russia, are fascinated by folk traditions and history and ancient myths and legends. And we will be coming on to someone else who is interested in myths and legends in the second half. We will indeed. But at the time when he was growing up, I think to his family, the idea that Chikovsky would be the great Russian musical vehicle for all this
would have seemed relatively unthinkable. Because although they have a piano, most Russians, as you said, have a piano, most Russian middle-class families, but in Russia, middle-class boys don't go on to become musicians. So when they go to the opera house or the concert hall, the musicians they hear playing are touring Western European musicians. It's not seen as a proper thing for someone like Chikovsky. to do? So to begin with, Tchaikovsky doesn't pursue a musical career. He pursues a much more
glamorous profession, which is to become a civil servant. And I'm not joking when I say that, because, I mean, anyone who's read a Russian novel will know that to be a civil servant is really quite something. Very prestigious vacation, very difficult to get into. Right, it is difficult to go into. So when he's 12 years old, his parents sent him to a boarding school in St. Petersburg, which is called the School of Jury's Prudence. That's where you learn to become an official. So he wears a military uniform. He has to swear an oath at the age of 12 to God, throne and motherland. And he has to work every day from 6 o'clock in the morning until 10 o'clock at night. And that is the routine, Tom, that we have replicated with our own producers, Theo and
Tabby. I think, I think, Dominic, you are flattering Theo there, who is never knowingly up before midday, but nice, you know. It's sweet of you to say that. So Chikovsky is there in this school until he's 19 and then he becomes an administrative assistant at the Ministry of Justice. But all this time he's been into his music. He's been writing waltzes and songs and things. And unlike most civil servants, he becomes a real dashing sort of swashbuckling man about town. And I have to say his dad is very impressive at this point. So he's about 21 and his dad sits him down and says, this civil servant thing, It's obviously not you. Why don't you go for music?
Why don't you try it? And so Chikovsky says, well, if Dad's saying that, I might as well. And he does. And the timing is perfect because the following year in 1862, St. Petersburg's first musical conservatory opens its doors, and Chikovsky is there.
Right. He's one of the very first students. And like a lot of students, he reinvents himself. He grows his hair long. He wears much more sort of raffish clothes. It's a kind of Quine, kind of Carnaby Street in the 16th? Well, as we will discover, slightly more San Francisco in the 60s. Yes, of course.
So he's sort of turning himself into an artist with a capital A. And eventually he gets a job in Moscow teaching music at the new conservatory there. So now he really has become a proper kind of working musician, a working composer. He teaches students. He writes songs, he writes little operatic pieces, a first symphony. And all the time, he is developing this. intensely romantic style, sometimes grand and sweeping, but sometimes very kind of delicate and intimate. Yeah, and we're going to hear an example of that right now, aren't we? And Dominic,
it's a song he wrote in 1869. Yeah. But because I don't speak Russian and because you are the master of tongues, perhaps you'd like to give the Russian title first before we come on to the English translation. Yeah. Close your ears, please, Oliver. It is niet cholko, tot, kutuzna. What is it? You heard. You all heard. Which, Tom, as you will know, translates as none but the lonely heart.
And a great favourite of Frank Sinatra, who recorded it four times. And sadly, Frank can't be with us this evening. But it doesn't matter because we have an even better singer than Sinatra. And that is Marta Fontanel-Simmons, who is going to perform None but the Lonely Heart for us now.
Now, Who knew, who know, Svite, I'm jasd'n, I'm jasdun. Oh, my God, how I stradall, and how I straddle. Look, I'm looking I'm in D'Aldnizzi, I'm from here, I'll gnailkne a-knit-n-lok-a-law-o-kaw. Oh!
Oh, my name, I'm blitzel, Oh, Luke. Oh, that only who knows I'm sorry, I'm sorry, oh, oh, how I'm
how I'm scared, and how I strah, oh, My blood-ca-giat-ca-gast-Gradal, I beg-last-a-blood. Sjah Grewd callit, who's my name's Ville d'nese bade?
I'm sorry, no, I'm yet, I'm yot, how I stradal, and how I stradal, and how like I stuards do. Thank you. You see, who needs Frank Sinatra? That was Marta, Fontaineau-Simmons, and the Philharmonia Orchestra, conducted by Oliver Zephemann. Absolutely wonderful. Now, Tom, I know your Russian is absolutely perfect, so you won't need me to translate any of those lyrics.
But just in case... For everyone else? Yeah, for everybody else. None but the lonely heart can know my sadness, alone and parted, far from joy and gladness. And they capture something, I think, that is central to Tchaikovsky's reputation. the great secret drama of his life, which is, of course, his love life. So, Chikovsky probably first fell in love when he was a teenager at the School of Jurisprudence,
and his love object was another student, a young man called Sergei Kiref, who was about four years younger than himself. Now, it probably wasn't a physical relationship, probably a case of adoration from afar, but then Chikovsky fell for another young man Alexei Apuktin who ended up becoming a poet and this probably was a physical relationship and it was the first of many in Chikovsky's life and I think it would be fair to say that the vibe of Russia in the 19th century isn't massively kind of gay friendly
is it so we are doing a series starting tomorrow actually on Peter the Great and he had decreed the death penalty for any hint of homosexuality in the army back in 1706, and then in 1832, Nicholas I, another Tsar, had declared that any civilian convicted of homosexual behaviour would be packed off to Siberia, which, to be fair, basically seems to be the response of Russian Tsars to almost anything. But most of these punishments were never carried out. And I think that's because in 19th century Russia, homosexuality, it wasn't, it didn't. It didn't. It didn't. It
didn't kind of define you. It wasn't an identity. It was seen as just being a taste. And so if you had money and if you had connections, the chances of prosecution, let alone conviction, were actually very, very small, weren't they? Yeah, they were small. It's really interesting. So as you said, homosexuality is condemned as a vice by the Orthodox Church, but it's fascinating that in all Chikovsky's life, there is only one tiny hint of scandal or public criticism. And that's a newspaper article in 1878 that was sort of muttering darkly about the teacher's love affairs at the Moscow Conservatory. And even though Chikovsky visited gay brothels, he went cruising in parks,
he made no secret of his affection for handsome young men, that was really the only tiny hint of public scandal in all his life. But that hasn't stopped Chikovsky's biographers since from kind of basically tearing each other to shreds over the question of whether he felt haunted by his sexuality or whether he was completely mellow about it. Yeah, so in the Soviet Union, this was a big problem for historians and biographers of Tchaikovsky.
And they went out of their way to play down his sexuality, and in fact, Soviet historians effectively went into the archives to erase material that they thought presented him in a bad light. But in the West, particularly, I have to say in Britain, people tended to play it up. So in the 20th century, Chikovsky became in Western scholarship. He was seen as the gay composer.
So first of all, kind of condemned as a hysterical neurotic and then held up as a hero of gay rights. But I mean, not saying that he's a hysterical neurotic, but there are hints that he struggled with his sexuality, aren't there? I mean, he finds it hard to sleep at times. He seems to become depressed. He gets, he has kind of nervous breakdowns occasionally. Yes, but that said, most recent writers point out
that he led a very active and indeed very colourful love life. In fact, I think we can safely say a little too colourful for 21st century tastes. Because he almost always fell for men who are a lot younger than himself. Boys. Well, he was particularly drawn to boys of about 14 or 15, which a lot of people may find very unsettling. So, I mean, he's kind of the Russian Oscar Wilde maybe,
in that sense. So a kind of a great gay icon, but a lot of his gay relationships are with people who are much younger than him. And so inevitably there is a kind of power differential there, isn't it? Yeah, I think that's fair to say. I think it's a pattern you see again and again in Chikovsky's life. So there's a musical prodigy called Vladimir Shilofsky, who's 14. Then there's a 15-year-old, a music student called Edward Zach. And Chikovsky had a real passion for him. and Zach actually ended up taking his own life a few years later. And a lot of this story is very murky because it was effectively erased by Soviet censors.
So it's very hard to say what exactly happened between them. But what we do know is that Chikovsky was absolutely devastated afterwards. And one of his biographers says, you sense the presence of a complex and intense psychodrama that is almost entirely hidden from view. And hidden from view, presumably because Tchaikovsky himself is trying to bury it. And so there's doubly a kind of darkness, a darkness that Tchaikovsky wants to bury the memory of this in. But also a kind of personal darkness that Tchaikovsky is feeling, kind of element of self-hatred, perhaps, almost depression.
I think that's fair to say. I mean, after Zach's death, he goes into this deep, deep depression. And then, as so often, he emerges with a great burst of energy. So it's 1875. He comes out of this depression. and his commission to write a ballet, and that became the piece we heard at the beginning, Swan Lake, one of the most beloved pieces in the whole canon.
And then a year after that, he falls in love again with a violinist called Joseph Kotech, who was then 21. When, for hours on end, I hold his hand in my own, passion rages within me with unimaginable force. My voice shakes like that of a youth, and I speak a load of nonsense. And Dominic, that is Tchaikovsky, not you. That's not me on, no.
That's not me talking about Theo, Tom. Yeah. That's Tchaikovsky talking about this bloke. So this is a letter that he writes to his brother Modest, his younger brother Modest, who is also gay. And they would talk quite openly about all of this, which leads me to think that Chikovsky's probably not quite as tortured and as repressed as we often assume. I suppose another issue is, I mean, honestly, I mean, who ultimately cares? Does this matter? Of course, in the immediate aftermath of Chikovsky's death,
there are lots of people who feel it does matter. So Chikovsky dies, and Tolstoy, who by this point is about 810, he writes, there is always something not quite clear about him, more as a man than as a musician, which I'm guessing is a reference to his sexuality, and certainly in the decades that follow Chikovsky's death, there are critics who condemn his music as an erotic and effeminate, presumably they are saying that because they're not really talking about his music at all.
They're talking about his posthumous reputation. Right. But I think with all of this stuff, it's important not to sort of blow it out in proportion. So there's a great music critic at the 20th century called Richard Taroskin. And he wrote a brilliant, brilliant essay on all this, which actually Oliver, our conductor, put me on to. And Taraskin said, look, we should stop seeing Chikovsky as this angst-ridden, guilt-ridden, kind of neurotic artist. By and large, this is somebody who is very successful. who has loads of fun, actually loads of money,
and is generally pretty happy. All of that said, Tom, you are right that there are issues, shall we say, because in 1876 he does basically the most unexpected and implausible thing you could possibly imagine. I mean, so unexpected, so implausible, that I think we should probably have a bit of music beforehand to brace ourselves for it. And what we're going to hear now is a piece he wrote in 1878
amid the great emotional crisis of, spoiler alert, Tchaikovsky's marriage. And that is what we will be coming to in a moment. But first, the third movement of his violin concerto, played by our soloist, The Brilliant Leia Zoo. Enjoy. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be.
And... No, I'm... ...there not... ...and... ...and... ...there... ...and... ...and...
...a... ...or... You know. Oh. Yeah. I'm going to be able to be able to do. I'm going to be. I'm going to be able to be.
I'm going to be. I'm going to be. So, you know, I'm I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. And then
. And... ...andahs ...and ...and ...and ... ...and
... ... I'm gonna'n't I'm gonnae'n't I'm gonna'n't I'm gonna'n't I'm not I'm going to be the
I'm going to be I'm going to I'm going to and I'm going to I'm going to I'm I don't know. I'm sorry.
I'm not I'm going to be I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to I'm going and I'm Oh my
Oh Oh I'm gonnae. And... ...and... ...and... ...and... Oh, I'm
Oh, and Oh. And Oh, She was the mrs. There are ...
... ... ... ... ... ... ... ...
I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to We're going to be able to be.
I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to I'm going to be. One of the I'm going to be the
I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be the I'm going I'm I'm going to be able to be.
I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. . I'm going to be able to be. I don't know. I'm sorry,
I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to I'm going I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to be. I'm going to be.
I'm going to be a man. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm sorry. I don't know. And...
And... Oh, oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh, oh.
Oh. Oh. And I'm . So, I'm gonnae. And... ...and...
...and... ...and... I don't know. I'm sorry. I'm Oh, so on the Oh, and so on Oh, and
you know, I don't know. Oh. Oh. Oh. I'm going to be able to be. Thank you. I'm gonna be it.
And... ...that... ...and... ...and... I don't know. I'm going to be able to I'm going to I'm going to
I'm going to I'm going to I'm I'm going on. I'm Thank you. I am.
I am. I am. We're going to be able to be. We're going to be able to be. I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be able to be.
I'm going to be. I'm going to be. Thank you. This episode is brought to you by the Philharmonia Orchestra, who are turning 80 this year. And to celebrate, they are giving away 80 free tickets for first-timers for every concert in their 20-25-26 London season. Now, if you've never booked with the Philharmonia before, you can choose any concert in their London season. They're all at the South Bank Centre. you can get two tickets completely free.
There is no catch. Just world-class music live. So the Philharmonia's first concert was in 1945 and ever since then they have been a part of Britain's cultural fabric, constantly evolving and always ambitious. They have scored more than 150 film soundtracks and video game soundtracks. They've collaborated across all kinds of genres, classical icons, jazz, they've even done heavy metal.
I mean, this is not just orchestral, it is adventurous. So, this is your chance to experience one of Britain's great orchestras and some of the world's top soloists in one of the world's great venues to book. Head to philharmonia.com.com.com.com.U.K. slash free tickets. Come for the music, stand for the ovation. This episode is brought to you by Hotels.com. Make your next trip work for you. Hotels.com just rolled out a game-changing feature called Save Your Way, and it's as simple as it sounds.
When you book a trip as a Hotels.com member, you decide how to use your savings. Choose to take the instant savings now or to bank the savings as rewards for later. It's your call. Envision converting discounts on this week's day into rewards for a luxurious beach getaway next year. No complicated maths, no blackout dates. Just you choosing how to make your travels work harder for you. Only at Hotels.com. Save Your Way is available to loyalty members in the US and UK on hotels with member prices.
Other terms apply. See site for details. This episode is brought to you by NordVPN. Christmas should be a time for relaxing and letting loose, but history teaches us that letting our guards down could allow bad actors to strike. Fortunately, in 2025, we don't need a turret or a moat to stay safe. We just need NordVPN. At the click of a button, NordVPN's powerful software encrypts your data
and Threat Protection Pro blocks malicious links and scans downloads for viruses. It covers up to 10 devices or can be attached to your router to protect your whole home. It also helps with your Christmas shopping. Online retailers can sneakily change prices based on your location. Fortunately, using NordVPN means you can buy presents with the peace of mind that you're getting the best price. To get the best discount of your NordVPN plan, go to NordVPN.com forward slash rest is history. Our link will also give you four extra months on the two-year plan. There's no risk with Nord's 30-day money-back guarantee. The link is in the podcast episode description box.
This episode is brought to you by Ancestry. Hello, James Holland here joined by Al Murray from Gollhanger's World War II podcast. We have ways of making you talk. These are those odd days between Christmas and New Year. The house buzzing with laughter, leftovers pile. High, festive films murmuring in the background, and trivial pursuit debates still raging round the table. It's the perfect time to sit close, share family stories and think about people who came before you. Grandparents, great uncles, aunts you hardly knew, everyone who helped shape the family you're part of today.
With an ancestry membership, you can take those conversations further. All you have to do is provide what you know about your family history, such as your parents and grandparents' birthplaces, and ancestry will help you dig through billions of records to uncover fascinating news stories about the lives of your relatives. Maybe it's a great uncle ferrying a hurricane north, a grandmother stitching uniforms in a Glasgow mill, or a relative holding the line on the Normandy beaches, and suddenly the stories around your own table take on a whole new depth.
The past isn't behind you, it runs straight through you. Head to ancestry.com.uk slash new year to learn about ancestry's memberships and start your family history journey today. I can't tell you what a privilege it is to be actually on the stage listening to such virtuosity, such an honour. So thank you, Leia. Just amazing.
So, Dominic, Chikovsky's marriage. I think we've established, he's very much not. the marrying kind of a guy. So what's going on there? I mean, does he think it's his duty? He's got to lie back and think of Russia. What's going on? Yeah. Chikovsky felt the pressure of social expectation, basically. I think he felt that he ought to get married, that it was the thing to do whether he wanted to or not. So already in 1868 he had proposed to a soprano called Desire Artoe, which I think is a sensational name for a soprano. Right. And she says yes.
Yes, she did, but it very quickly, I think much to his relief, fizzled out and she married somebody else. But then in 1877, he started getting letters from a young woman called Antonina Milikova. And she had very briefly been a student of his, a music student. Now, Chikovsky had completely forgotten her, but she had certainly not forgotten him. She had developed this great crush on Chikovsky. And she's basically starts sending her these letters. She's a super fan, I suppose. And he agrees to meet her. And at the second meeting, I think very recklessly, he asks her to marry him. And immediately she says, oh, yes. Brilliant. And Tchaikovsky thinks, I have made a huge mistake. And so the wedding when it happens
is not 100% the kind of wedding that a bride dreams of, is it? Because they get married in Moscow in July 1877. And when the priest says to Chikovsky, you may kiss the bride, Chikovsky responds by bursting into tears. Yes. Yeah, so the wedding night's not a bundle of laughs either. Because as soon as they reach the hotel, Chikovsky, in sort of desperation, takes a massive sedative and goes straight to sleep. And poor Antonina has no idea what's going on. But it's fair to say nothing much is going on. Right. Because a few days later, Shikovsky writes to his brother and he says, look, I find my wife
absolutely repulsive. And Shikovsky capable of great charm, but not on this occasion. No, not on this occasion. So he's very miserable. He's made a terrible mistake. He thinks about throwing himself into the river Moskba, but in the end, he basically flees to the countryside and leaves
Antonina behind. And not just to the countryside, right? I mean, he basically goes on a massive European holiday. So he goes to Paris, to Florence, to Rome, to Vienna, desperately trying to think of ways to avoid her. And then in the middle of all this, I mean, it should really have been his honeymoon. His great love interest, Joseph Kotech,
pitches up in Switzerland to see him, which I imagine doesn't help with his kind of, I should really get back with my wife kind of thoughts. So you may remember from a few moments earlier that we said Kotech was a violinist. So this is actually the moment that inspires Schaikovsky to write the piece that we have just heard, the violin concerti. And when you listen to it, you can feel there's this kind of incredible sense of excitement.
So, I mean, a musicologist must hate this kind of talk, but perhaps there's a sense there of the frenzy of passion that he's feeling for Kotech. But also, it's a little bit mad, isn't it? Yeah. And maybe that's the effects of his marriage. Well, here's a really mad thing. So the mad thing is that that piece that we've just heard played so brilliantly got one of the worst reviews in the history of classical music from the great Viennese critic of the day,
Edwa Hanslick. Hanslick said that listening to that was like being in hell. He said, Chikovsky has proved for the first time the hideous notion that there can be music that stinks to the ear. I mean, that is mad. Well, I mean, Thomas, we often tell rival podcasters, rival history podcasters. You should never let the critics get you down. That's so true. So, too. So, Dominant, just two questions, and I'm guessing the answer to both these questions is no. Did they ever consummate their relationship? They did not. And did they ever get back together?
Again, they did not. So he went back to Russia, he asked Antonina for a divorce. She said no. They separated, but they didn't divorce. He did give her financial help later in life. And they did sometimes meet, but he was always, I have to say, very cold and almost a little bit cruel when they met. And actually, by and large, when people talk about the great company, They always overlook or indeed a downright rude about the wives.
So perhaps we should spare a thought for Antonina. She had a really rough time through no fault of her own. She actually ended up going mad and ended up in a lunatic asylum. So it's a very sad story. And there's kind of sense that meeting Tchaikovsky isn't always great for your long-term mental stability here, isn't it? And I wonder, Dominic, whether it was worse for Anthony, precisely because she had been such a fan. And they separate, just as Tchaikovsky is about to embark on the kind of, you know, the absolute pinnacle of his career, so the 1880s.
He's become a massive national, actually an international celebrity. And people are comparing him to Mozart and saying that he can turn his hand to anything. Well, I mean, not anything, obviously not marriage. No. But symphonies, concertos, ballets, you name it. Basically, Tchaikovsky can do it. Very Mozart. Yeah, and this is not just a question of Tchaikovsky's genius.
It's also a question of the context. So in the 1880s, Russia obviously has some pretty major political issues which culminate in the Russian Revolution, but culturally, it's a very rich and self-confident and sophisticated place. Now, the Tsar at the time Alexander III is a massive reactionary, and he is very keen on the idea that Russia is distinct from the rest of Europe, that it's sort of set apart by its Slavic history and identity. And so for Alexander and his court,
The idea that Chikovsky is a distinctly Russian composer with a distinct Russian style, borrowing from traditional folk melodies and songs and whatnot, that becomes really, really important to them. Despite the fact that this is exactly the kind of thing that is going on in countries across Europe. So Sibelius is doing it. Vaughn Williams in New Course will do it.
So what does the Tsar say to that? But the Tsar doesn't give a damn about that time, I think it's fair to say. So the Tsar to the Tsar, he doesn't give a damn what Sibelius is doing. all that matters to him is that Chikovsky is a sort of authentic Russian hero. So in 1884, he invites Chikovsky to St. Petersburg to receive the order of St. Vladimir. Extraordinary honor for a composer. He gives him a ring as a personal present.
And he also gives him a lifetime pension, which is a sign of just how much Chikovsky is valued. So putting the marriage to one side, his life is pretty good. So he's got his pension, he's got his kind of honor. He's very popular. he's kind of famous and he even has a kind of very well actually the kind of perfect patron who's a woman called Nadejde von Meck
and she's the perfect patron because they never meet but she just chucks loads of money at him and also he's a massive star in America isn't he? Right so he's actually very like us he goes to New York in 1890 he conducts at Carnegie Hall he loves it
the thing he loved most when he came back and he couldn't stopped talking about. It was the telephone in his hotel. He was amazed by this telephone. And he kept ringing the reception just to kind of try out the phone. Very like Theo Young-Smith on our American tours ringing for room service. He was never off the telephone, was he? And then when he gets back home from America, he gets to work on one of the most joyous and celebrated things that he ever wrote. And that is his ballet, The Nutcracker. And the good news, Dominic, ladies gentlemen
is that we are now going to hear two of its most glorious moments right now the sad news is that we are not going
to dance to it but you can't have everything right right We've got... ...because ...and...
...you know... ...that... ...and... ...and... ...and ...so... ...and ...a...
...and ...and Oh, I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm gonna be, D. And...
I'm on the I'm... ...and... ...a... ...and... ...and... ...and... ...and...
...a... ...and... Oh. Oh. Oh. Mm. Mm. Mm.
Mm. Mm. Mm. Mm. Mm. Oh. Oh. Oh.
Oh. Thank you. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. I'm gonnae. And so on the I'm gonnae'n't I'm gonna'n't
We're going to go to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be. We're going to do. I'm going to be able to be. ...their... ...and... ...their...
...and... ...the... ...that... ...you... ...the... So that of course was the dance of the sugar plum fairy and the Russian dance, both from the Nutcracker and Dominic, it's starting to feel a lot like Christmas, isn't it? Because, of course, the nutcracker, the story of a wooden nutcracker doll that comes to life at Christmas. Yes, and that was first performed in St. Petersburg in December 1892.
So at the time, Chikovsky was 52 years old. He was at the peak of his powers, the peak of his popularity. And he's probably got, what, 20 years ahead of him writing unimaginable masterpieces. But just a year later, his story takes a tragic twist. So on the 10th of October, 1893, Chikovsky arrives in St. Petersburg by train, and he's planning to stay with his younger brother, who we've already mentioned, Modest. And Dominic, we're going to be talking about the history of St. Petersburg in a couple of weeks on the podcast, because, of course, we're doing Peter the Great, and St. Petersburg is founded by Peter the Great,
on very marshy, very boggy land, a lot of mosquitoes, and so it is notoriously, unhealthy, isn't it? Right. It's always been plagued by cholera outbreaks, one of which is raging in the autumn of 1893, and all the restaurants have been told by the authorities that they have to boil their water before giving it to the customers. But 10 days into his stay, the 20th of October, Shikovsky goes out with his mates on the Nevsky Prospect, and they go into a restaurant, and he asks for water. And the waiter says, we've just run out of all the boiled water. If you Hold on a little while, we'll get you some more. Chikovsky says, I don't want to wait.
I'm very thirsty. I'm sure it's fine. Just bring me a glass of unboiled water. You can probably guess what's coming. The next day, he complains of feeling unwell. He says, don't call a doctor. I'm sure it'll be fine. Three days later, by the time they do call a doctor,
it's obvious it's not fine. And so it is that at 3 in the morning, on the 25th of October, 1893, Piotr Iliic Chikovsky died of kidney failure. Or did he? Because, Dominic, you know I love a mad conspiracy theory. You do. And it's fair to say that even at the time,
there were people who were skeptical of this whole unboiled water story, and they said that Chikovsky would never make such a stupid mistake, and therefore there must be a more sinister explanation. And actually, you've said how Mozart was Chakofsky's great, hero. There are elements here, aren't there, of the rumors that start to spread around Mozart's death, the possibility that perhaps he'd been murdered. And aren't there historians who kind of dabble in these kind of waters about Tchaikovsky? There are indeed, yes, who dabble in these murky waters. So a very good example is an eminent British historian biographer called David Brown, and he suggested
that Chikovsky had taken poison, that he'd killed himself under pressure from his old schoolmate. He said basically a schoolmates had convened this court of honor and they had handed down their verdict that Chikovsky must either take the decent way out or they would expose the secrets of his sex life. And what credibility do you give to this theory? You know my methods, Tom. I find this very unconvincing. You see, first of all, Chikovsky doesn't strike me as a man who is haunted by guilt or anxiety or fear in the autumn of 1890. Actually, he's on Cloud 9. He's just finished his sixth symphony. He's in very good form.
Actually, I think behind all this, people struggle with, I think, the idea that a superstar, an international celebrity of this kind, an artist, could be cut down by something so random and so meaningless and banal. And I think people also struggled at the time, especially with the idea that cholera,
which was a disease that afflicted the kind of urban poor, the starving masses, could have carried off such a great man. I think they found that very hard to reconcile. Now, for me, I think probably he did have cholera. I think the boiled water story, as bizarre as it is, is probably true. Anyway, what we do know is that his funeral was a massive deal. It was the first commonest funeral ever to be held
at the Kazan Cathedral in St. Petersburg, and it's a sign of his celebrity and his importance that 60,000 people applied for tickets. So that's Tchaikovsky, not just. us dead, but now buried. And Dominant, I wonder, can you give us your verdict on Tchaikovsky? Where does he stand in the history of music?
So, a lot of people would see him. Well, he's undoubtedly Russia's most beloved composer. I think there's a very good argument that he's Russia's greatest composer. There have always been critics who have dismissed him as a bit lightweight or a bit easy, as a bit too audience-friendly. I don't think that's a bad thing, by the way,
being audience-friendly. I know you don't, darn it. The comparison with Mozart, I think, is a good one. I think nobody since Mozart could do so many different things so quickly and so skillfully. And more broadly, Chikovsky has come to represent the idea, the musical idea of a Russian soul, the idea of Russia itself, sort of torn between Europe and Asia, east and west, all of that stuff. And he would have loved that, wouldn't he? Because he was a massive patriot.
His country meant so much to him. What was the thing he was saying about? He said that I've never come across anyone who loved Mother Russia more than I did. Right, exactly. So basically, he is to Russia, well, you are to Britain. Oh, Tom. Love it. Thank you.
That's very kind. That's kind. You're welcome. You're welcome. Well, to capture that, there is one work, of course, above all. And this is the work that really captures, I think, is Russian patriotism. And it was commissioned in 1880 for the opening of the Cathedral of Christ the Savior in Moscow. And this cathedral had been commissioned years before, hadn't it?
And it was designed to serve as a memorial. to the sacrifices made by the Russian people in their defeat of the invasion by Napoleon, which had happened in 1812. Napoleon had occupied Moscow, but had been defeated by the Russian strategy and by the winter, and had been forced to retreat in terrible circumstances,
had ended up getting frostbite and eating frozen horses and all kinds of things, and you look gutted at this failure of French strategy, Dominic. Absolutely devastating. History is regular. and listen to the rest of this you will know, is littered with French catastrophes. And this is one of the most purely enjoyable. Anyway, Tchaikovsky, he agreed to write a short piece of music for the opening ceremony,
and this piece captures the whole story of the 1812 campaign. So you get the kind of melodies of the Russian Orthodox Church, you get folk tunes, you get Tom, the strutting bombast of the Marseillaise. Strutting bombats. You get bells, you get gunfire. You get celebrations and you even get cannons. So it's literally a banger, ladies and gentlemen. By far, Chikovsky's most popular work
and I think there is no better piece with which to close his story and this half. Right, well, before we have the music, let me just remind you that we were back after the interval in the second half with the life of Richard Wagner. Now, can I just ask, are there any members here of the Restis History Club? Well, that's very good to know.
And as always, the good news for you club members is that you can hear that second half right away. You don't have to wait. Add free. But I'm afraid the rest of you will have to wait until after the interval. It's such a bargain, isn't it, Dominic? It's such a bargain.
But for now, we leave you with Oliver Zephman, with the Philharmonia Orchestra, and with Chikovsky's 1812 overture. Thank you. ...and... ...that... ...their... ...and...
...there... ...and... ...and... ...and... ...and... ...b... I don't know. I'm
I don't know. I'm going to be able to be. I'm I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to be. We're going to be able to be able to be. I'm .
And... ...and ...and ...and ...and ...and ...and ...
... ... We're going to be able to be able to be. We're going to be the mrs. I'm We're going to be.
I'm going to be. The POMAYOR. I don't know. I'm going to be able to be. We're going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I'm going to be.
I'm going to I'm going to And... ...and... ...theirred... ...with... ...which... ...the...
...with... Thank you. We're going to be the same. We're going to be able to be. I'm going to be. We're going to be able to do. We're going to be able to be.
And so on. We're going to be able to be. We're going to be able to be. I'm going to be. I don't know. And so, you know, and
the I'm . ...whoe, and ... ...and... ...that... ...and... ...the...
...and... ...and... ...you're... I don't know I'm going to be able to I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to
I'm I'm going I'm I'm going to be able to be. I don't know I'm gonnae'n't know I'm gonnae'n't I'm
know And so, I'm going to be able to be. I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to be able to be. And... ...you know,
...and... ...withal... ...you know. ...and... ...and... ...that... ...and... ...the...
...and... ...and... ...and... ...and... I don't know. And... ...withal... ...and...
...their... We're going to be able to be. We're going to be. I'm going to be. I don't know I'm gonnae'n't know I mean... ...when...
...their... ...and... ...the... ...the... ...that... ...you know... ...and... ...and...
...and... We're going to be able to be. And so on. We're going to be able to be. . And... ...then... ...their...
...their... ...you know? ...the... ...the... ...and... ...the... ...or... ...the...
We're going to be able to be. I don't know. I'm sorry. So, you know, I'm going to I'm going to be able to be.
I'm gonna'a. ...andahe . ... ... ... ... ...
... ... ... ... ... ... ... ...
...hehran... ...for... ...and... ...and... ...the... ...the... We're going to be able to be. And so on,
we're going to be. And so on, you know, We're going to be able to go. I'm going to go. We're going to be able to be able to be. We're going to be able to be. We're going to be able to be.
We're going to be able to be. ...andemps... ...and... ...withal... ...when... ...their... ...and... ...and...
...the... ...an... Thank you. Thanks so much for listening. We will be back on Thursday in 2026, our first episode of the year, and that will be with the second half of that show that we recorded at the Royal Albert Hall. And the focus of the show will be the most controversial of all classical composers, Richard Wagner.
I hope you enjoy it. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Hello, I'm Professor Hannah Frye. And I'm Michael Stevens, creator of Vsauce. We thought we would join you for a moment, completely uninvited. We are not going to stay too long, unless you want us to, of course. We're here to tell you about our brand new show.
The rest is science. Every episode is going to start with something that feels initially familiar. And then we're going to unpick it and tear it apart until you no longer recognize it at all. Yeah, banana flavor doesn't taste like bananas. Yeah, what is that about? So it is supposed to taste like an old species of banana that was wiped down in a banana apocalypse. And now you will only find it in botanical collections in the gardens of billionaires. Wow. Banana candy is actually the ghost of a long extinct banana.
So if you like scratching the surface, thinking a little bit deeper or weirder. Yes, definitely that too. You can join Michael and I every Tuesday and Thursday wherever you go. get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.